non
les amis comme vous le savez nous sommes
tous réunis pour un seul objectif faire
disparaître est éliminé cyril ah non non
non je vous préviens il est hors de
question que je participe à cette
opération criminelle
on prendra aussi son salaire alors je
vous préviens il est hors de question
que je laisse tomber
bon à côté de ça et le feu à gaza
qu'est ce que tu fais là je fais juste
mon petit story pour dire qu'on fait une
opération secrète bon pour que cette
opération restent secrètes et anonyme
nous allons tous nous attribuer les
pseudonymes et non de ville moi par
exemple ça sera pour la reine
géraldine sera bourse de stars sera mon
cul
maxime
café mais qu'a fait c'est pas le nom
d'une ville dont il va ne chercha cup
alors moi je me disais comme chez
originaire pris trois générations de la
région du fai anglais est ce que je fais
pas mes mamies c'est bon pour toi c'est
lourdes voilà vraiment de réflexion au
cul et moi comment je m'appelle je ne
sais pas tu as mal et on voit la partie
c'est un des noms de villes toi paris
brest
[Musique]
les amis comme vous le savez nous avons
un but très précis éliminer cette
personne annonce apparemment c'était le
thème d'une réunion précédente
je parle évidemment de cet individu
alors grâce à montcuq ici présents
bonjour vous avons élaboré à prout
non non on avait parlé d'un putsch moi
j'y connais rien en push mais j'ai déjà
faire baver explique notre avec un push
alors c'est ça une goutte de jus
d'orange et trois villes de ronde non ça
c'est un push
là on part d'un putsch c'est un coup
d'état ou un soulèvement organisé par un
vie en général restreint pour s'emparer
du royaume très intéressant on s'en fout
complètement bon est ce qu'elle est
question oui quand est-ce qu'on marche
les questions en rapport avec le putsch
et mais quand est ce qu'on mange pendant
le pitch
[Musique]